hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast live stream number 21 which I
believe is prime I am Dr Brett Weinstein
you are Dr Heather hying and it is if my
calculations are correct past the
midpoint of winter almost no matter how
you define winter I imagine you could
Define winter different ly but uh if you
define it in a reasonable way either
taking the shoulder Seasons into account
or strictly going U from the winter
solstice to the Spring Equinox yes we
are we are halfway through we are
halfway through we are now I was
puzzling through this you follow uh
these celestial events more diligently
than I do but I was thinking about the
question of initially I convinced myself
the midpoint of the technical winter
would be the point at which the day
length would changing most rapidly but
then I thought nope I don't think that's
right I think it changes most rapidly at
the Spring Equinox is that
correct um boy I'd have to remind myself
uh I'm
not is is the day length changing the
most rapidly at the equinoxes I think
that's right but uh it's possible there
are little perturbations oscillations in
there such that you actually have two
two rapid but no I I think that's right
I think that has to be right because uh
do we agree that it is changing least
rapidly at the solstices yes okay so
then but there's a there's a question
about whether or not there's you know
just like you know seasonality in the
tropics okay so seasonality in the
temperate zone uh is mostly about hot
and cold uh but whenever you take
students to the tropics whenever you
yourself go to the tropics you're REM
okay it's not really so much a hot cold
thing because uh given that day length
doesn't vary very much the closer at all
when you're at the equator
uh you don't expect uh temperature to
vary very much what does vary though and
what is often highly seasonal even in uh
rainforests which um which have you know
some wetness throughout the year is
precipitation is rainfall you know and
the higher up you go it may be um
precipitation hanging as water droplets
and Cloud forests um but in um even
lowland rainforest jungles colloquially
uh you do have seasonality and you have
wet and dry seasons is what they say but
it's really wet seasons and wetter
seasons um but it's not one wet season a
year and one dry season a year you've
got like a longer wet season and a
longer dry season and a shorter wet
season and a shorter dry season so I
don't know if there might be and I I
can't imagine why there would be um but
we've but there's so many you know
orbits to to be accounted for and and um
and angles
um that I that I don't know if there
isn't a uh a quickening of uh the photo
period
change as you approach the equinox and
then as you go away from the Equinox
with maybe a little dip in there and I
like I don't think the physics works but
I don't think there's a dip but I do
think there are two things that match
your description and both of them will
play a role but I bet it's tiny yeah and
in fact we've been here once before and
somebody uh weighed in saying that our
model was correct um that you shouldn't
imagine perfect symmetry here but the
two things that are going to be relevant
are um the rate of change at the spring
and fall equinoxes m is that how you
pluralize Equinox
equinor I'm going to go with equinoxes
just to be perfectly safe and
conventional sure um but I always are
the rate of change should be slightly
different at the two because of course
Rel to one another right that one of
them will truly be the fastest moment uh
of change in the year and the other one
will lag slightly behind it um and and
that the reason will have to do with the
uh the non Perfection of the ellipse of
our orbit yeah um and so anyway there is
some question the year should not be
divided perfectly into four quarters
because we're not going around the Sun
in a perfect circle and there's a parag
and an apy question which will adjust
the speed of our hurdling um yes so
something like that absolutely yeah yeah
all right um yeah but you but you're
right and um we are halfway through
winter more than halfway through winter
and and you can tell it is so much
lighter out now uh at at 4:30 at 5 even
than it was a month ago and it feels
good yeah well yeah the temperature
change has been radical from that deep
dip to uh very mild and now it's a
little colder but and here just I I
don't know so the demm minder the app um
that uh we started talking about about a
couple years ago when we were when we
started getting focused on oh maybe
there is no flu season maybe it's
vitamin D deficiency season um all right
uh and you suggested this app and and I
do use it um I have not vetted it for
accuracy so that's just the the caveat
here the disclaimer at the top um but I
was in Portland this week which is what
160 180 miles south of here something
like that and the demm minder app tells
you how many at this point in the year
at this this far north and as far north
as Portland uh there's no D that can be
made at all at any point throughout the
day uh and it's been several months uh
the difference in how many days it's
going to be before you can make D
according to the DM minder app uh in
Portland it's something like seven days
from now and up here it's 16 days from
now that's actually a substantial that's
and I I think I have those numbers right
in which case that's 18 more days a year
up here less than 200 miles farther
north uh that you cannot make any D at
all yeah that's a big difference for a
small Traverse over the Earth exactly
that's a that's a really big difference
and you know it's it's about the angle
of the Sun in the sky the angle I think
the sun needs to be I think it needs to
be above 30° um uh above the Horizon
before uh it's possible before it's
possible to size yeah yeah yeah which um
I think is going to be I'm almost
certain is going to be about the amount
of atmosphere that it has to penetrate
before it reaches you um I will also
just say anecdotally I was thinking
about the fact that we are halfway
through winter a little Beyond now could
have been something like February 5th
would be halfway I
think you
know if you divide it evenly by by
calendar but you know given that the
months aren't equal lengths and actually
this I didn't know we were going to talk
about this but this did occur to me that
is is summer the longest season given
when we set our um set our dates because
there's two 31 month days in summer and
there's no other span of time with two
consecutive 31 month 31 day months Sor
sorry 31 day months well I don't know
there are musical traditions in which
summer is considered endless and I'm
very fond of these Traditions though
they turn out to be lies um but still
but anyway Noble lies I would say yeah
they're good ones it's it's sort of it's
sort of a a positive positive sentiment
if factually inaccurate sure but I was
noticing a lot of that us being you know
halfway through through winter
um that I believe personally and I think
it is true across the whole family um we
have not gotten all of the little
nagging colds and illnesses that often
accompany this season heard a while yeah
and I would say and a lot a lot of
people are sick yes a lot of people are
sick and we have been I I can't say that
this is causal but I can say we have
been very diligent over the last couple
years about supplementing vitamin D and
I think even more importantly when you
are in a place where vitamin D can be
made um doing so deliberately going out
during the right hours not wearing more
clothing than one needs because the more
surface area you have exposed the better
you do at it and I don't know could be
happen stance could be noise but
especially given that it's not just one
person right if it's all of us yeah and
we're paying more attention that's more
likely to be accurate I still vastly
prefer not to not to feel that I have to
supplement yep uh and I do not uh in the
non you know maybe maybe a month on
either side of of winter but really not
outside of that at all and I have always
pursued the sun um I I was never a
sunbather per se but I have I have
always um and you I I cheated my own
photo period in in graduate school by
going south of the Equator for my
research in the northern winter months
all of this um but I but but I was
always prone to um laryngitis and cold
and and a little bit to flu and such and
um yeah all of us and it's and and we're
taking D but we're also in this time of
year taking C and magnesium and zinc and
uh
and these things anecdotally and a four
seem to be working yep I would also say
I've been lucky to have traveled we've
traveled some to the tropics uh in this
season and I traveled with Zach one more
time and definitely made use of it uh
vitamin D wise but that cuts both ways
because my my anecdotal sense is that as
much as going to the tropics is helpful
traveling on airplanes is the opposite
um yeah
um you know this the story the airline
industry tells yeah about their
filtration yeah about their filtration
and the UV filters and and all of this
uh is somewhat compelling yeah but it's
not it I think that is compelling at the
level of the recirculation I don't think
there's much that helps you if the guy
behind you is coughing and You're
vulnerable because you're deic no I I
think you're right and I think um you
know that I think um that the first I
got covid in February 2020 was on a
plane back from La yeah uh and uh you
know the guy across the aisle from me
who had actually was assigned to the
seat that I was in and I didn't I didn't
realize that he
took he took my seat because the seat I
ended up in was broken um but he had sat
in it for a while I was I was lant on
the plane he had sat in it for a while
and he was hacking across the aisle the
entire time and he had been hacking in
the seat that I was in and dripping and
all of this and
and I got super super sick so uh you
know I don't I don't I don't know um
obviously usually whole plain loads of
people don't end up sick but if you're
right in the sphere of influence you
probably do have a chance yep I was
reminded of that uh episode in our
family history Zach also got sick at the
same time yeah I'm
s um anyway I was reminded you know in
dealing with all of the various back and
forth about whether there was a novel
pathogen if there was a novel pathogen
whether it was actually Co I was
reminded of that because at the time Co
didn't occur to us because it wasn't
supposed to be present and um yeah but
here's the interesting fact that I
remember I remember but a month later I
was like what wait a minute right it's
had to have been but at the time I
remember a looking at you two as sick as
you were and thinking having had a
history of being very vulnerable to
respiratory diseases I do not not want
what they have and I was quite afraid
that I was it was going to be impossible
to avoid it being in the same uh house
with you guys as sick as you were yeah
and I remember also it's an odd anecdote
but I was staring at the thermometer we
had one temperature thermometer um for
taking a person's temperature in the
house
and I was staring at it thinking I
should take my temperature and see if
there's the indication and I was
thinking why that it's sterile yeah and
you know that that seems a crazy thought
to me I'm sure I had used isopropyl
alcohol on it but you guys were
anomalously sick even before we were
thinking Co had anything to do with this
right and you know the term that
ecologists use uh for organisms that can
survive or indeed Thrive an
extraordinary circumstances are
extremophiles Y and especially since we
didn't know what this was um and you
know it's still there's still a question
as to you know how robust the thing is
and you know maybe which what thing it
is yeah uh could you know it's not a you
know deep sea hot vent extremophile it's
not a sulfur pool and Yellowstone
extremophile uh but extremophile is a
thing that you know that natural
selection uh can can create from some
you know rare mutation and go like let's
run with that because that's working
right now so uh you know of all of the
ways to potentially you know if the goal
is spread yeah if the goal is virulence
and in the modern world uh it's you know
you're being very careful and you're
staying away from people but you share a
thermometer that might well be a mode um
that is discovered by would be
extremophiles there's no evolutionary
reason something couldn't uh discover a
mechanism to get through the um the
bottleneck that we attempt to create
with something like isopropyl alcohol
all the one thing that does protect us
is that to do so a pathogen would have
to surrender other capabilities right um
for reasons of trade-offs so
um you know I don't I don't expect to
see that pathogen and I I think my
concern about the thermometer we now
know whatever was circulating did not
have those special capacities and indeed
wasn't fomite transmittable at least at
first at all and as far as we know still
isn't um but nonetheless the the reason
it was important to me was just I have a
data point that says I was looking at
you and looking at Zach and thinking
whatever they've got that's odd this is
not the normal thing um that people have
now could be an anomaly but um but there
was something weird about it even before
uh we were thinking in terms of uh SARS
K2 no and it's and it's worth thinking
you know if uh you know probably
probably at that point I don't remember
exactly but probably we could have
afforded another thermometer sure and
um you know you you don't get two of
everything that you might possibly share
within a household there's uh there are
reasons that people live together Beyond
wanting to be in each other's company
and some of those are economic ones
right so you don't need more
thermometers right uh however however
thinking it through and thinking through
like okay uh this risk seems low on the
other hand um if I'm wrong and I get
this sickness uh those those Stakes just
went so high that maybe it's just worth
not taking that risk actually I now even
remember better what I was thinking
because I was looking at this
thermometer right and it wasn't a glass
thermometer it was electronic one and so
there was a seam where the metal tip
intersects with the plastic and like
question was all right is is there any
way that a pathogen could get in there
and not be touched by the isopropyl
alcohol right now obviously if you
soaked it in the isopropyl um no but
that I mean that's that there it is
right I mean this you know entirely a
Mercury based entirely encased in glass
glass thermometer you just dump that
thing yeah you just you submergent
isopropyl or hydrogen peroxide and and
you know sterilize it and be on your way
but uh yeah yeah all right um not really
the top of the hour anymore but uh I
think we need to get to our uh our ads
but I just want to say uh we're uh live
streaming on Rumble please um whether or
not you tend to watch or uh listen on
Rumble please come over to the Darkhorse
channel on Rumble and and join there
that actually helps us out we're trying
to get to 100,000 subscribers by middle
of April yeah helps us free to you yeah
free to you um and uh and then also um
there's lots of stuff going on at our
locals uh which uh there's a there's a
watch party right now and you you guys
have put up a lot of what you did in
Panama uh up there behind our our locals
pay wall so uh consider joining us there
there good stuff and there will be more
stuff put there I would just ask one
other thing um I try not to pay
attention to this but I am crawling and
have been crawling towards a million
Twitter uh followers forever right it's
been very very slow for some reason that
I does not feel organic but maybe it is
some on the scale or an ass on the scale
could be something like that but anyway
um if you haven't uh if you haven't
followed me on Twitter I'd appreciate
that one as well also free and if I'm
going to say impertinent things all of a
sudden that's going to be the
spot yeah sometimes here occasionally
occasionally yeah okay so um we only do
uh two q&as a month at this point and um
and there's not one today when they do
happen they're also on local so again
another reason to join us there um and
then we're just going to bring a our ads
before launching into the rest of of the
show we as always have um three sponsors
uh whom we carefully vet and choose and
so you can be sure that if we are
reading ads um we actually truly vouch
for these sponsors and so without
further Ado you are first yeah all right
you can tell because it says our first
yeah no no if had I read it ahead of
time that would have been the thing but
um our first sponsor this week is MD
hearing we have friends and family who
have hearing loss there's a good chance
that you do too while we don't have a
need for hearing aids ourselves we have
a good friend who does we asked her to
assess MD hearings newest product
carefully and honestly her testimonial
is at the end of this ad MD hearing
makes highquality simple and effective
hearing aids free tiny fraction of what
most hearing aids cost helping bring
audio Clarity and capacity to people who
might not otherwise be able to afford it
MD hearing was founded by an ENT surgeon
who made it his mission to develop a
quality hearing aid that anyone could
forward MD hearing is an FDA registered
rechargeable hearing aid that costs a
fraction of what typical hearing aids
cost MD hearings brand new XS model
costs 90% less than Clinic hearing aids
you don't need a prescription which also
means there's no
middleman here's the newest testimonial
from our friend who has substantial
hearing loss and who relies on hearing
aids we asked you to try MD hearing's
newest product and this is what she said
MD hearing aids new XS hearing aids
MD hearing MD hearings new EXs yeah
see it's an editing error MD hearings
new XS hearing aids are powerful energy
Neo you you excuse me dropped the
Relevant Word though it's called the Neo
the Neo the White
Rabbit do it man all right I'm now going
to read you think if I read all the
words on the page it'll be right I think
it's fine okay yeah MD hearing aids new
Neo excess hearing aids are powerful
energy efficient and Tiny wow that felt
good they come with settings for quiet
social noisy and restaurant situations
the battery life is over 18 hours with a
short recharge time the restaurant
setting actually works better than the
restaurant settings on my far more
expensive pair amplifying sound within
several feet of me and muffling sound in
the rest of the environment wow sounds
like I could use them hate noisy
restaurants all right back to the
testimonial yeah I that's good yeah what
maybe you should maybe I should I also
tested them in a room with a white noise
generator in Discord voice chat and on
phone calls with and without speaker
phone as with the previous sets I've
tested the only significant difference
between these and my usual set hearing
aids that cost about 12 times as much is
smartphone integration with app control
with that single exception MD hearing
aid is making all the hearing
functionality of very expensive hearing
aids accessible to everyone all right
end of testimony
so if you want MD hearing smallest
hearing aid ever go to shopd hearing.com
and use promo code Darkhorse to get
their new
$397 when you buy a pair offer that's
shop MD h e a r i
n.com and use our promo code Darkhorse
to get their new $397 when you buy a
pair offer why excellent okay not
excellent at at the reading level
excellent at the quality of the hearing
aid level yeah yes so we
hear so we hear that's a pretty good
slogan right there yeah yeah it's all we
here all right our second sponsor this
week is Helix Helix makes truly
fantastic mattresses that are supremely
seep enhancing uh and while I am going
to read this ad straight um after this I
will say that I was away for six nights
and I came home and slept on our Helix
mattress last night next to you and it
was such a relief so great such a great
mattress part of that was about being
back with me but absolutely and then but
yes and then it
was disen hanced what's the word wow dis
enhanced that I mean that may even be a
new word yeah by the by the cats who
were very grateful to see me who I am
not a good substitute for you when it
comes to those cat cats and their
preferences yeah yeah yeah so but even
with even with the cats and their
preferences the mattress uh made for an
excellent night's sleep have you ever
been traveling yes I have and climbed
into bed only to discover that the
mattress wasn't comfortable yep
conversely have you ever experienced the
feeling of relief when you discover a
great mattress uh one that lets you
sleep comfortably through the night
Helix is that mattress it's amazing what
a difference it makes Helix sleep is a
premium mattress brand that brand that
offers 20 different mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences take the
Helix sleep quiz online and in less than
2 minutes you'll be directed to which of
their many mattresses is best for you do
you sleep on your back your stomach or
for your side do you toss and turn or
sleep like a log do you prefer a firmer
or softer mattress all these are taken
into consideration with the Helix sleep
quiz and they have special mattresses
for Big and Tall adults and one for kids
as well once you found your perfect
mattress it's shipped straight to your
door free of charge then you'll have a
100 nights to try it out without any
penalty if you love it which you
probably will they've got 10 to 15E
warranties on all of their mattresses
every Helix mattress combines
individually wrapped steel coils in the
base with premium foam layers on top
providing excellent support for your
spine and comfort for for all of you
Helix has been awarded the rank of
number one mattress by both GQ and Wired
Magazine Helix mattresses are made in
America at their very own manufacturing
facility they're built for human bodies
and built to last Helix also supports
military First Responders teachers and
students by giving all of those groups a
special discount not on mass but
individually yeah uh we've had our Helix
mattress for well over a year at this
point uh and look forward to it
providing us with years more of
excellent sleep Helix is offering 20%
off off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com Darkhorse and use code
Helix partner2 this is their best offer
yet and it won't last long with Helix
better sleep starts now it is an awfully
good mattress yeah it just is and
finally our final sponsor this week is
ancient it's armura Arma is colostrum
colostrum is the first food that every
mammal eats produced in the first two or
3 days of an infant's life and is
nutritionally different from the milk
that comes in afterwards mammals have
existed for three 00 million years give
or take a few tens of millions of years
and the first food every mammal has
eaten is colostrum colostrum serves many
vital functions including that of
protecting and strengthening the muc
mucosal barriers of infants before their
own barriers mature modern living breaks
down your mucosal and immune barriers
and armor is the superfood that builds
it back armor colostrum protects and
strengthens your body's barriers
creating a seal that guards against
inflammation and everyday toxins
pollutants and other threats Arma uses
their cold chain biop potent technology
to concentrate colostrum 400 plus living
nutrients into the most pure and
bioavailable form according to a review
published in the journal Clinic
nutrition open science in 2022 bovine
colostrum has been used to treat cancer
AIDS polio heart disease and rheumatoid
arthritis it is a general
anti-inflammatory and its use in adults
is known to increase lean muscle mass
improve athletic performance and
recovery time support healthy digestion
and reduce allergy symptoms armor starts
with sustainably sourced colostrum from
grass-fed cows from their Co-op of dairy
farms in the US they source only the
Surplus colostrum after calves are fully
fed and unlike most colostrums which use
heat pasteuri pasteurization that
depletes nutrient potency armor uses
their cold chain biop potent technology
an Innovative process that purifies and
preserves the Integrity of hundreds of
bioactive nutrients while removing
cassine and fat to guarantee the highest
potency and bioavailability of any
colostrum available on the market the
quality control is far above industry
standards including being certified to
be glyphosate free benefits of Armor's
colostrum also include clearing of
blemishes shinier thicker hair
stabilization of blood sugar levels and
acceleration of fat burning and
colostrum has been shown to
significantly improve Fitness endurance
and significantly decrease recovery time
after intense exercise armor has a
special offer for the Darkhorse audience
receive 15% off your first order go to
Tri ara.com Darkhorse or enter Darkhorse
to get 15% off your first order that's
TR AR
rm.com
Darkhorse you ever look at mammals and
think that's a really weird thing to
have covered them
in some a little bit but not not really
because honestly I look
at I look at more basil reptiles
um who have um the thing that hair
evolved from which is
scales and I think yeah I get scales and
I feel like I get fur um but then I look
at Birds yeah which are also reptiles
and um and I look at what their scales
have turned into and they still have
scales you look at their their legs and
such they do have scales um but then
feathers are also homologous with and
downstream of uh of of scales and I
think if you if you got to if you're
thinking scales feathers fur which is
weirdest I'm going with feathers well I
think feathers are coolest the level of
the um the geometry that causes the
filaments of the feather to function
like little self adherent zippers that
thing's pretty awesome and that's only I
mean and there are multiple types of
feathers on almost all birds as well so
that's that's uh that's feathers yeah
like feathers I think those are like
primaries yeah I mean well I'm not an
expert on many different kinds of
feathers there are lots of Downy
feathers that don't have that thing on
them but then there are also lots of
different kinds of feathers on a
flighted bird that that do the zipper
thing but anyway the the thing that
weirds me out about fur m is a the huge
amount of surface area to it yeah right
you ever rinse a paintbrush and it takes
forever to get the paint out of it
because you've got all of these
cylinders covered in paint on all sides
or hair yeah same same kind of thing
like why does this take so long right so
why would if you had an animal that was
in danger of getting into
something gross Maddie um why would you
want all that surface area where that
stuff can stick and be
to to get off and then also it provides
a landscape for parasites and you know
obviously creatures with scales and uh
creatures with feathers have those
parasites too but it seems to me but
they kind of go in in between oh yeah
like tick will go in between scales on
the lizard and such um but yeah fur
things can really get burrowed in in the
fur it also provides um uh an
environment for all Factory
communication though I mean and and
inadvertent all Factory indicators of
what kind of gross things you might have
rolled in M sure if you're if you're
mammal is going to go into an old
factory you would want
it uh oh you're giving me that
look sorry I just you know auditorily it
yeah it does and and actually there's
just you just add a D in this case so
that's all you got to do just if you
have a spare D lying around you just put
it in all fact and you're after the
races um but uh the other thing is isn't
it just okay it's primarily i w say
primarily it is one of the main uh I
don't know if it was the driving force
in the evolution of fur uh or it was one
of several contributing factors but
Thermo
regulation f is great creates a boundary
layer it's lovely when dry and the
problem is that an animal that's doing a
perfectly good job uh therm regulating a
cat that gets wet right suddenly has a
problem therm regulatorily speaking Yeah
I guess I don't know and I don't I don't
know that anyone knows I don't know um
you know fur is not going to tend to
fossilize very well right uh but there's
OB there's some extent mammals uh and
relatively late arriving on the scene uh
that even when wet um their fur still
has a high insulative qual uh capacity
like sheep
yeah or otter but otter is different but
but sheep like the the woolves of sheep
and goats like Casmir goats and and lots
and lots of sheep with all the wools um
still do great even when wet and uh you
know you know this if you if you wear
wool and you got like well I'm GNA you
know if if I don't have a way to keep
the rain off of me um I'm going to be
warmish far more than if I wore cotton
for instance uh but I am going to smell
like a wet sheep like that's no matter
how Marino it is like how much they try
to strip all the Sheep of it um you're
still going to smell like a wet sheep
when your wool gets wet um but otters do
a different thing yeah right they they
they actually have a layer um of of air
the fur is so dense that the water can't
get to the skin so it keeps there not
even air just okay but I mean that
proves you can you can adapt fur so that
it does something amazing in terms of
thermo regulation with respect to water
but presumably the early mammals didn't
you've all you've all looked at a wet
cat and thought Oh that's a pitiful
looking creature right this has gone
from this Sleek
amazing uh you know Triumph of evolution
to a pitiful you know uh Critter until
it dries out so I don't know I I just I
mean I'm a mammologist as you know I do
think it was an odd choice and not a
perfect one yeah and then of course you
have the uh the fact that uh we are in
some anthropological circles known as
naked Apes yeah and whenever this would
come up when we were still professors
when when I would say this I would get
you know students be like but we're not
you know we're not naked you know we
have plenty of fur like no well okay
there there are spots right um but but
mostly we've got and lost it and uh and
that is highly unusual you know the
Aquatic forms yeah um some of the
Aquatic forms have have lost their fur
not all of them other as we've talked
about but um but the other the other
main I guess the three other evolutions
of aquatic mammals Revolutions of
aquatic forms and mammals evolves the
cations the whales including the tooth
whales the Dolphins and and orcas um
manatees and
dongs and the pinnipeds the seal sea
lions and walruses seal sea lions and
walruses who spend depending some time
on land have weird like very sparse kind
of coarse hair is think any mammal has
lost it entirely none right but they but
none of them have Rich coats they're
they're they're mostly furless mostly
hairless uh and who else naked W rats um
yeah and then you know the bat centurio
cic has lost it from its face there L
lots of lots of places where it's
disappeared but yeah um but even I mean
I don't know how much we actually now
know about why our lineage did lose so
much of its fur but I take it actually
to be an indication know exactly the
thing I'm pointing to here which is that
we got a better deal by being able to
use the fur of things like sheep or
skins of other animals or whatever that
that gives us more um it gives us a
higher return on investment than having
a fur coat of our own which you're stuck
with when it's hot I mean you can
obviously have a different coat in the
summer than the winter lots of creatures
do that but being stuck covered in fur
all the time has downsides and we
because we can technologically
substitute something don't suffer from
all of those
downsides I wonder I don't I haven't I
don't know if this is in the literature
or not but um with primates all but us
of which have fur although some of them
have bare patches um you have a
reduction in the sensory focus of the
rest of mammals on all faction our our
noses shrink and our eyes get bigger and
they move to the front so you have
frontation you have binocular vision now
uh and uh for all the rest of mammals uh
all faction was really a primary way of
communicating and we don't do it as well
we we can and we don't sense smells as
well as other mammals and as I mentioned
earlier uh hair is you know in the
places that we've retained hair actually
um underarms and groins it it they they
do um accumulate secretions that have
odors associated with them that do
communicate to other individuals and
broadcast it really affect
broadcast very effectively but I wonder
if the loss of hair um doesn't mean that
we're broadcasting less of that uh than
than we would have been which is useful
if we are hunter gatherers which we were
for a very long time and if we can't
detect our own smells as much because
our doses have shrunk and our eyes have
taken over all that brain real estate uh
then it would be useful not to be
spreading odors that we can't tell
because we would get in the way of our
own hunt yeah well like it probably
untestable yep at least during the
podcast right yes there's just there's
no time there's no budget there's
there's definitely no budget time
traveling machine being expensive as
they are yes
absolutely okay uh I believe that you
wanted to start this subject matter even
yeah this was subject yeah it was it was
just it was impromptu yeah which is
good um yeah I wanted to talk about uh a
few different things the first one has
to do and it's funny I told you uh what
I wanted to explore and then in trying
to find uh some example visuals I
convinced myself that I was I was using
a label that wasn't optimal okay so what
I wanted to talk about was out of my not
what I have been calling overfitting and
overfitting is a term that exists in
statistics but it has been taken over
the majority of thinking on it is now in
places like machine learning okay and um
so I'm going to say a little bit about
what overfitting is and then I'm going
to say why I don't think it's the right
term and suggest some others um
overfitting you want to put up that
visual Zach um overfitting is a quest so
this is a in a modeling context and the
idea is you're so those dots are a
scatter of some
phenomenon and in this case in this this
is a hypothetical example the dots have
a kind of curve to their distribution
but there's also a lot of noise the dots
don't all land on the curve and this is
the way data in a complex environment
almost always is because so many
different factors impinge on the
distribution of of the data
points so overfitting is the case where
you force the model to embrace all of
the fluctuations in the dat
and you miss the overarching thing that
explains their pattern most usefully and
so the problem in a machine learning
context is if you train your machine on
this data and it overfits it gets all
the noise in the data and it includes it
in the model then that model correctly
predicts the data that you train it on
and doesn't predict any other data set
because the noise will be dissimilar and
I should just remind people when we talk
about noise noise is always the result
of other processes that you're not
interested in it's not fundamentally
noise you could study those other
processes if you wanted but if you're
interested in for example let's say you
were interested in the
relationship
between um interest rates and home
buying and you looked at the rate of
home
buying there'd be a lot of noise and one
of the factors would likely be the
weather and how conducive was to home
shopping right is is it the kind of
weather that gets you to want to go and
drive around and look at houses which
then results in people making offers and
buying homes or not so you would weather
is a factor but if you're looking at the
influence of interest rates weather is a
is noise right you could also ask the
question also also called a confounding
variable right confounding variable um
but so if you're building a model what
you want is the right number of factors
so that your model that you build based
on observations the inductive part of
the process then becomes predictive of
behavior in other contexts where you can
say well the interest rate is doing X I
expect the rate of home buying to do y
um like that okay so that's what
overfitting is is the tendency to uh
include too much in a model so that it
fits the exact pattern that you've seen
you want just put that visual back up
and since some people can't see it uh
walk through I think it's a nice clear
visual I don't know if you want to give
its source but um underfitting here is
also nicely visualized um because uh
what people who haven't been in
this in this area before may not
recognize is that it's very easy to say
draw a line Y right so to to ask uh to
ask an algorithm or
um or you know to just say I'm going to
draw a line a straight line through
through data uh and and the fact is that
many times uh an XY plot uh a straight
line is not the best fit and so you know
you're talking about underfitting
overfitting well best fit is also uh the
word that we'll tend to be used now you
know and just right you know it depends
on what you're trying to do right um so
you know I think that this is good
because it's it's vague it it's AB it's
totally abstract right we don't know uh
what it is that is being plotted here um
but it looks
like uh the straight line misses real uh
variation uh at low X right and the
overfitting line uh captures way too
much variability that will probably
render that um unuseful as you say so
let's let's actually it is this is
obviously not a real graph of anything
um but let's throw something at it that
has such a pattern so that you can see
why why this is important let's talk
about uh mortality versus age if age is
on the x axis and the number of
individuals who die at that age is on
the y- axis so Y is the dependent
variable then we do have in uh many
creatures including humans we have a
increased level of mortality in the
first year of Life which then becomes
spectacularly low if you survive your
first year and then it goes up uh it
doesn't go up exactly the way this graph
does but the point is there's a curve to
it that does have higher mortality at
the very beginning it drops to a minimum
and then it climbs over the course of
life and if you decide that what you're
looking for is a line you will get uh an
underfitting situation where you miss a
very real pattern which is the
vulnerability of neonates um if you and
indeed infants up to about a year yeah
right um and so then if you know if you
were to graph uh if you were to
graph a particular population's rate of
death you would have things you know
there'd be disasters and accidents you
know even even healthy 25y olds die
sometimes sure you could have uh you
know
bad uh Trends on Tik Tok that result in
people falling off of crates you know
whatever whatever the noise I mean that
was a thing for a while crates yeah
people were stacking those plastic
crates I don't know what the crates are
actually used for but they're see now
the herbologist and me heard KR AIT yes
you that like people are standing on
piles of writhing venomous snakes you
wouldn't want to do that Tik Tok does
not allow that sort of thing no they're
piling crates okay piling crates however
c a t s yeah milk milk crates for
example um so anyway you don't want to
overfit you don't want to underfit what
you want is a model that captures the
the important Trend and the outgrowth in
machine learning and uh models that are
not machine operated to the extent that
still exists um is that it's predicted
of data sets you haven't yet seen right
it's predictive of Novel data not just
matches the data that you fed into the
thing gu how useful is that right okay
so that's overfitting and underfitting
now the thing that I've been describing
as overfitting is the tendency of people
in a non-machine learning nonstatistical
context um to see in data or by the way
this is a pet peeve of mine I have said
this out loud I don't think yet but
almost always when people say data they
would be better off saying evidence um
data is a kind of evidence but it is not
the only kind of evidence so you're safe
if you say evidence even if you mean
data but you're not safe the other way
around in this case since we are
actually talking about data points data
is a defensible term but in the context
of people who have a belief about the
world they are interacting with there is
a tendency
to
force the observations to match the
model right so that is not a perfect fit
for overfitting because in the case of
overfitting you're talking about
matching the model to sample data and it
failing to predict new data and in this
case what you've got is people who take
every new observation and they force it
to their model so I'm going to propose
that the right term for this is going to
be either shoehorning right for forcing
things into a pattern that they don't
fit um or straight jacketing where
things observations that should falsify
your model actually are unable to escape
it and I want to point to a
particular uh one of the my guess is
this is a general category and that
those terms are generally useful but the
one I see is actually one I have a
little sympathy for okay okay so here
here's the the setup
yeah we don't know how to deal with
collusion I'm avoiding the word
conspiracy because it has so many bad
connotations but if we say collusion
collusion is conspiracy and the problem
is when people realize that they are
living in an era where they need to
think about collusion because it's
actually not a minor fact of our
environment they do not understand that
they have stepped into a realm where the
philosophical toolkit the scientific
toolkit that they've been handed now has
a challenge that has to be addressed
with extreme care and the hazard is
this boy I was not expecting to go this
deep into the philosophy but let's take
aam's Razer for a second aams Razer is
the principle that um the simplest
explanation for a given set of
observations tends to be correct all
else being equal right all else being
equal and I would also say that the
problem with aam's ra is that it is
simultaneously the fundamental principle
of science that the way we decide what
is likely to be true the way we update
our models of the universe over time is
that we apply the principle of parsimony
right there's a set of things that are
facts and whatever explanation we have
that explains those facts either by
assuming less or explaining more and
hopefully both whatever integrates the
assumptions at the lowest level and the
explanatory power at the highest level
is the explanation it's our it's our
working
model and my argument is that actually
aam's Razer simplest explanation tends
to be true could be rephrased as given
all of the evidence the simplest
explanation is always true if you had
every if you if you had infinite
information about every observation from
every side then the simplest explanation
that explained all of it with the least
assumptions would always be right and
when you land on when when when you find
yourself in possession of evidence of
conspiracy for instance or collusion uh
and if you turn out to be correct part
of what you have discovered is uh that
you knew less about the system than you
thought right and so the example that
makes this perfectly clear is the
process of framing right if we say you
know uh Ned was convicted of murder and
then somebody says yeah but he was
framed right what they are alleging is
that the reason that the evidence led
the court to convict him was that
somebody organized the evidence so it
would point to this guy yeah right so if
we take this example what the court saw
the simplest explanation is that Ned
Comm committed the crime right if the
court had had access to the fact that
there was a meeting of people and at
that meeting a transcript of the meeting
would reflect well how are we going to
arrange the evidence so that the cops
pick up Ned and he's then convicted if
you knew that that meeting had happened
then the point is oh well in light of
that evidence the simplest explanation
is that Ned was being railroaded for
some purpose right so okay in the
universe if you had all the evidence
then aam's Razer could be phrased much
more strongly and it would be a law not
just a
principle but we never have all the
evidence so at the point that we are
talking about collusion we are
inherently talking about some analog of
framing right collusion always involves
the evidence leading you to a wrong
conclusion so that point is I'm going to
deny you the evidence of our meeting and
I'm going to leave you with the evidence
of X Y and Z and given that you have a
bias and you can see this evidence and
you don't know the evidence you can't
see you're going to reach a wrong
conclusion that's what collusion does
right
so at the point that you
come to the conclusion right or wrong
that collusion may be an important
feature of the environment that you're
operating in you have to become suspect
of aam's Razor because the question is
well why is that the simplest answer is
that the simplest answer because it's
really the simplest answer or is it the
simplest answer because I'm standing
where I'm expected to stand and I'm
processing the information that I'm
expected to look at okay so okay that's
great so now you've got people who are
interested in collusion who are aware
that aam's Razer may be misleading them
aam's Razer as it is phrased not as it
is actually true in the universe with
all the evidence
available so what do those people do
well what they do is they turn down
their dependence their Reliance on aam
Razer which is the correct thing to do
if you don't have all of the evidence
and you want not to be fooled by
those who would collude against you you
get more uh creative in allowing your
brain to make connections between things
100% you free yourself from the normal
rules of logic in order so that you
could see what might be going on and
there's nothing wrong with that that is
actually necessary however you cannot
then decide that the quality of your
thinking is as it would be if you were
in a laboratory where you controlled all
of the inputs and you knew that the lab
bench wasn't conspiring against you so
the point is you itself I mean you know
in a universe where the bench conspires
against you then you can't rely on the
fact that the contents of the test tubes
are really telling you anything because
it may be that the bench is tricking you
using the test tubes somehow but that's
not how it works in the world of people
we mislead each other and so
um yes you have to relax your standards
in order to think about collusion no you
don't get the same level of strength of
conclusion out of it you have to be more
careful than regular folks doing regular
work on you know if you go into the
field and you study the behavior of
frogs as you did right you don't have to
worry that somebody is arranging the
frogs because what would have to be true
a why would anybody want to trick you
through frogs and B what would they have
to act you You' see them arranging the
frogs before you got to your study site
so you can just assume the frogs are
probably doing whatever the frogs do
nobody's trying to trick me right but
the Realms where that's not true you
have to relax your standards but you
also have to treat your conclusions with
a kind of skepticism that is very rare
amongst those who actually think about
this stuff so anyway what they do is
they do this straight jacketing or
shoehorning thing and I'm in a weird
position now because you
know I now am the subject of many a
hypothesis of
collusion you can be pretty sure they're
not true you can't be as sure as I can
can be but you that that you aren't
involved yeah right but in terms of
people who don't know us haven't known
us for years who've just come across us
on the internet right they don't know
right no and nor should they I mean we
have to just just as we say to everyone
always said to our students we have to
earn your trust right you do not simply
trust us because we have the right
credentials certainly not because we've
seen that abused for hundreds of years
so my point is look I am in a great
position to watch the behavior of the
people who are doing this work in public
because they're talking about me and I
can be certain of whether things that
they land on are true or not in many
cases right so the point is oh Brett's
one of the new Gatekeepers and he's part
of a network of cross promoters that the
mainstream blah blah blah is using to X
Y and Z it's like well okay let's start
at the bottom of that tree of uh that
tree of contingencies one of two things
has to be true either the allegation is
that I am knowingly part of such an
entity in which case I would know it you
would and you on the internet can't know
for sure that I'm not lying to you but I
can know that your accusation is
inaccurate and so I can say oh this
person is sloppy because they've landed
on a conclusion that they're certain of
and I know it's wrong but uh the
argument will come back and this was the
alternative to you might know it maybe
you don't know it maybe you're part of
this uh this vast conspiratorial network
of uh future Orthodox agents and you
just don't know it unwitting now if I'm
an un unwitting agent of these people
well I can't be certain that's not true
but then again it means nothing because
the point is we know we live in a world
full of propaganda which is people
trying to persuade us of things that
aren't true so that we will you know
mouth off on Twitter about them or
whatever so the point is okay either
this is an empty accusation or it's a
wrong accusation if it's you know you're
you're an agent of Goliath and you don't
know it well yeah okay may be but you
might also be um if it's you are a
witting agent of Goliath and the answer
is well I know you're not going to take
my word for it but no you're your logic
is sloppy um so shoehorning of your of
your two possible terms shoehorning uh
doesn't really have a connotation Beyond
like got a thing and I'm going to fit it
into this other thing but straight
jacketing does have this additional
connotation of once I get you into this
you are
constrained uh and I think that some of
what you're seeing some of you're you're
responding to here is uh frankly driven
by a desire to constrain you a desire to
have to steer you in a particular
direction um as opposed to just making a
pronouncement because they think they're
so clever and have uh overfit what they
see onto on to a guy that they think
they know because they see him on the
internet well I think you're pointing to
a level I wasn't going to get to which
has to do with why people are sloppy and
let's put it this way we are all human
beings with uh interests in the world
right you and I have endeavored to be
very careful and we have tried to reach
the truth as rigorously as possible to
do our work in public we have made
errors we have corrected them it's
painful but the point is you and and I
are more or less
functioning as I hate the term brand but
our identity is we're going to do our
work on public in public and we're going
to try to get to the truth and you can
come along for the ride and you can
watch us do this and you can disagree
and we may even hear you disagreeing and
respond to you and all of that and
actually
um maybe entirely but certainly almost
entirely this is this is draft yep right
like this is this is not like the the
book that we wrote that was a final
product and it's got errors and such in
it too but that was meant to be to have
staying power and to be something that
we can refer back to and other people
refer back to and that's you know that's
the nature of reference of of the
written word right and uh this and
it's you know it's it's it's far less
prepared than you know it's it's not
inherently the nature of the spoken word
I always prepared a lot more for
lectures right um but this is okay let's
let's figure out some things that have
that look
interesting and do a little dive into it
and then
talk actually without having had the
conversation in advance yep and see
where it goes and uh boy you know it's
there there's no net yeah it's it's
risky um but it's precisely the
willingness to take that risk and to
then come back when uh when we made
mistakes in doing so and saying say ah
you know this was wrong and here's how
we know or here's how we found out and
here's how how you might have known or
he how here's how we might have known
advance that that wasn't the right way
to go and it is that process that mean
that that is what the
phrase teaching people how to think not
what to think means y that's what it is
let's let people in on the process by
which we try to discover what is true
yep here we go is dialectical
exploration
which as messy as can be but the point
is you're not getting my perspective
you're not getting your perspective
you're getting the dialogue that happens
as we try to hash out what is being said
and what its implications are but here
here's the
point you and I there's no
point I could I could write a script in
which it would be true but there's no
point if your identity is dialectical
exploration if that's the reason that
people come to your channel if that's
the reason that people choose to support
you there's no point point at which
diverting from that program and
embracing something you know to be wrong
makes sense right even if you're going
to lose a bunch of standing for
admitting some major error it's always
better because you don't know what we're
going to be talking about two weeks from
now to get back to the place where
people rightly trust you because they
know you're honest about owning up to
your errors so our incentives are well
aligned with a public that wants to know
what the hell is going on right doesn't
mean that what we're seeing is accurate
but it means that our motivation is not
Divergent from your motivation for
tuning in right we are aligned in this
regard right or wrong okay I don't know
what the motivations are for the people
who are engaged in the shoehorning and
the straight jacketing some of them seem
to be
um
incapable of accepting that others are
seeing the same picture and so the point
is that person's not really seeing
they're motivated because they're an
agent of Goliath and Goliath blah blah
blah so this the thing that I watch
happen is there is an Embrace of a model
which facilitates the shoe horning and
the straight jacketing and produces a
kind of unfalsifiability
so the the term I'm going to introduce
here which we've talked about before is
limited hangout yeah okay so so if you
say threet is a limited hangout what
that means is that somebody in an effort
to prevent people from waking up is
going to provide you with something that
contains shocking elements of the truth
but that there's a cap on how deep the
truth goes right so you could imagine
that there's some job in which what you
do is you present a sanitized version of
the truth that prevents the really
explosive of stuff from
emerging now on the one hand do I
believe that limited Hangouts exist of
course I do absolutely I think that this
has been an important feature of our
landscape since the Kennedy
assassination at least where we see lots
and lots of exploration of the nonsense
that's obvious in the story of that
assassination that contains elements of
the truth fused to elements that are
nonsense and so the point is
it prevents us from ever reaching
resolution on what actually happened so
yeah limited Hangouts exist again either
limited hangout means you know that
that's what you are or it means nothing
because it means that somebody has you
know let you see part of the truth but
they're still obscuring something else
which is almost undoubtedly true for all
of us so if it means something you know
Bret's a limited hangout and then Brett
would know that he was a limited hangout
then I also know that this is wrong but
then it allows ows me to go and look at
what happens in the context of somebody
leveling this accusation M what happens
is they now have a model that has built
into it an immunity to falsification
it's not just a verificationism but it
has an immunity to falsification because
anything I say that's shocking and seems
to go against Goliath's interests oh
well he's a limited hangout I told you
that yeah and of course he's going to
he's going to give you the shocking
stuff that's how he gets you to join his
audience and then it limits what you can
see because now that you're listening to
him you're not going to get the real
stuff right which only we real people
are trafficking in right so the point is
okay well you've now built it's so
tiring yeah it's tiring but it's also
fascinating and it is
um it is interesting to be on the side
of it where you actually know for sure
that it's you don't have to worry as we
do with other people about whether there
really are a limited hangout because in
my case I'm I'm just in a position to
say nope right but I mean I mean you
just you just alluded to it um in this
landscape in this
era we all need to be concerned about
where we are getting our information and
who the people we are getting our
information from actually are and and
what they're up to yep
and I think in part uh you but also you
and I together
uh doing this every week uh have
generated not just Goodwill but the
trust of people and and we were able to
do it um I think you know for for a few
reasons um because the evolutionary
toolkit um forces you to be uh a a
careful rigorous thinker if you are
wielding it with uh with any kind of
precision as opposed to just sort of
waving your arms and looking for cool
stories um but also because of the
particular particular academic jobs that
we had um that allowed for and really um
you know were the most rewarding when
you really did go deep with students and
explore things that were going to be
uncomfortable and counterintuitive and
not what they wanted to hear and
sometimes you know um comfortable and
intuitive of course um but that that
means that we have a sort of a a a
toolkit that that has history
and that most academics don't have that
uh because it's never really expected of
them and and you know one thing that is
one thing that has been said many times
that has nothing to do with us in
particular in fact it it goes the other
way um is that uh you know conservatives
until the colleg is completely broke
down say 10 years ago 20 years ago
conservatives in college undergraduates
um maybe emerged with college degrees um
being able to think somewhat more
rigorously uh than liberals in college
at least if they were getting degrees in
like the social sciences and Humanities
because um their beliefs were put to the
test over and over and over and over
again and that makes you a better
thinker and that should be less true
over in the Sciences where your politics
should not impinge on what what ideas
that you are having that are being put
to the test but of course that's a pure
world and it's not quite like that uh
but I don't even I don't know if that's
exactly the case at most colleges now
because they're all broken but uh anyone
who has had to uh defend what they beli
to be true from a wide variety of people
who is therefore being leveled up by
being forced to be a generalist if they
even if they weren't before because even
if they think of themselves as someone
who is very much a specialist if I have
to respond uh you know if if you're Luc
aturan and you are TR he's trained as a
chemist but is he even trained like if
you're yeah if you are Luc aturan and
you have almost certainly discovered the
actual mechanism of w action which is
not the mechanism of vaction which some
people received the Nobel Prize for but
if you have actually discovered the
mechanism of vaction and you go to uh
professional meetings before they stop
inviting you and you go to you know you
you go to various places where you're
invited and you enrage the people in the
audience because it doesn't fit with
what uh with what it is that they are
sure is true you start getting questions
from the physicists and from the
biologists from the biochemists and from
you know all of these other people and
who have backgrounds completely
different from you and they think
they've got the gotcha questions and if
they never
do everyone should be more and more
convinced over time that maybe you're on
to something and you as Luca Turan in
this story um become ever more Adept at
understanding the scope of the
scientific story that you actually
sitting on yep uh and there is something
very powerful in every one of these
cases about what happens when there is
no script when there's transparently no
script because what you're involved in
is you know and there is a a scene in
the Emperor of sent um the trans bur
book about Luca Turan right there is a
scene
that where Burr as the journalist is
reporting on Luca Turan facing a hostile
audience asking him questions and the
level at which he is a virtuoso in
answering them because he has been
through every piece of logic any
question that they're asking is
something he's thought about a dozen
times and he knows why it's not a
devastating question and so he's just
he's just voling the stuff back and
forth and you know it's quite clear that
you know it'd be one thing if somebody
scripted Luc aturan to be a wouldbe
genius who knows the the answer on some
topic and it's not what the mainstream
says right you could script that so it
would look like that but what you can't
do is make it function like that in a
hostile Q&A and this is this is so far a
field here but this is often how uh
Hollywood and other literary forms get
the nature of Genius wrong right they
they they when when they put especially
scientific Geniuses up on up on screen
right and they just they're clearly on
script they don't ver they don't go off
script like actually no the brilliant
people go up script and that's how you
know yeah it's been it's been beautified
in a way that Rings Hollow just the same
way when Hollywood portrays you know the
hacker you know defeating the ticking
whatever bomb you know it just it just
doesn't look right anyway um but okay so
you've got this model and you've got
people uh uh the model is built so it
doesn't require any effort anything that
goes against the uh your model gets
shoved into the well of course they
would do that that's how they get you
through the door yep you know and then
anything that goes you know with your
expectation that they're not seeing the
full picture is well of course that's
that's their purpose as a limited
hangout so anyway the point is look
that's just sloppy that's just sloppy
and it's not the right way to think
about collusion even though though
limited Hangouts are real and propaganda
is real and being wrong is a feature of
the landscape for all of us unless there
is one and this is a digression maybe
return to it another time but a lot of
the people doing this their claim is
they actually had Co right from the
beginning all right right now there is
one way that you could have done
that and the way you could have done
that is is with total cynicism about
anything you were told and the problem
with the co landscape was that because
everything was distorted a total cynic
actually had an advantage in that they
didn't accept anything and that meant
that all of those pieces of
just didn't get through but here's the
point that's not I'm not saying maybe
you are smart and that's how you arrived
at a level of cynicism that was
appropriate to the propaganda but you
have to have arrived there though if you
start if you start from either Faith or
cynicism then that's not
uh that's not a flexible and therefore
uh an intelligent position right you
will in other words you have to out
compete an inanimate object for
resistance to propaganda right a chair
doesn't accept any propaganda it doesn't
make a chair clever right so you know
I'm not there are some people who I
think did arrive there early as a result
of a carefully refined uh model that was
ahead in detecting the level of cynicism
but not very many right that's that's a
rare position and um those people will
have made mistakes too
because because it's a complex landscape
and you know try you know if you if you
mentioned covid if you mentioned SARS
kovi 2 then the point is you're already
in the landscape of trying to sort wheat
from chaff right and the point is there
was an awful lot of sha yeah um but okay
um
so there's there's one more level
here in addition to just the basic
argument you are a limited hangout and
therefore I can you there's nothing you
could throw at me that I can't fit into
that model so this actually this is the
this is the reason that overfitting is
on my mind it's not that what they're
engaged in is overfitting at the
technical definition that I provided at
the beginning MH it's that they are
failing to detect their own own having
engaged in overfitting right at the
point that they have a model that um
fails to predict the future right if it
were a machine the people who program
the machines would say there's something
about this model that's wrong is it
overfitting right at the point that it's
a human being doing this they don't
detect it they do not so for example um
I took all kinds of crap as you know for
my Tucker interview the first of the
recent ones um
that was over the question of covid yep
and the um the point was that this was
the new narrative gatekeeping blah blah
blah um that you know Goliath is trying
to regain control over the covid
narrative and
so I just have to say at one level
anyone who thinks you're a gatekeeper is
clearly never met you I you even if you
wanted to you just don't have the chops
right no it's just not it's not did I
put that gate um uh sorry that could be
a scandal it could be gate gate yeah
yeah um yeah also the bad puns not you
don't want a gatekeeper who can't resist
the opportunity to make uh a pun it's
just not effective but um anyway the
point is all right if people were
crowing about my uh inappropriate use of
rhyme in declaring that there was a
dream team which again what I said was
all the smart people are on it and a
bunch of people were like why am I not
on it
well gee I think you may have answered
your own question but okay so they're
all crowing about gatekeeper and you
know Brett thinks he's in charge of the
dream team which I of course never said
um I just said there is one and it has
all the smart people but anyway okay so
people are crying about this
then I end up back on Tucker talking
about um the migration The Invasion that
appears to be embedded in the migration
or at least that's a viable hypothesis
and the even scarier hypothesis which we
may talk about later about whether the
MRNA vaccines that were distributed
Across the Western World could be
somehow involved in that hypothetical
Invasion embedded in the very factual
migration um that should have caused
people who thought I was some kind of
new
gatekeeper and Tucker is some kind of
new gatekeeper should have caused them
to say huh that doesn't sound like
something that Goliath would want talked
about at this level but instead what
they did was they resorted to this model
that cannot be escaped right and the
point is aha yes there were those of us
who were on this for years and years and
years and you're a latecomer and what
you're doing is you're trying to get
ahead of the story or whatever they're
saying so they had a
falsification well but is it the same
pupil yeah it okay oh yeah yeah they've
become because I mean there's so it's so
hard to track and so many of these
accounts aren't individual organic
beings right uh who are who are doing
things of their own accord that one of
my default assumptions is you're always
going to get the same kinds of arguments
uh whenever they could plausibly fit
right now and almost it doesn't matter
that these arguments are inconsistent
from moment to moment from you know if
if if if that's true now it wasn't true
then and therefore your argument doesn't
fit well that's that doesn't matter
because um these people if it really is
organic people or people paid by some
entity whatever um just just to cast
suspicion and fog on you and Tucker
Carlson and me like in everyone um you
know if the point is not uh we're going
to put together a coherent story like
you're you're living your life and it's
a coherent story it's got It's
incoherent moments you decohere
sometimes but like you know it's it's
it's a Lifeline right it's a it's a it's
you know from it's one timeline uh and
it feels obviously like anything that
comes at you and we've all experienced
this people with you know five followers
on whatever social media platform
they're on and presumably experience
it's like some some person comes in from
outer space and make some comment you're
like well that that's not that's not no
that's not what I said or that's not who
I am or that's not relevant and you have
the sense of like sure surely that's
obvious like surely you know that that
couldn't possibly like no no no they
don't care they don't care about your
some of them do simply do not care some
of because the point is um make it more
poisonous to be interested for other
people who don't yet know who might be
waking up uh make it harder for them to
want to come on board yeah and I think a
lot of it is not organic and I have a
little
rubric I look for um when somebody's
following account exceeds their follower
account um by a lot especially if
they're especially fond of posting uh
reposting material rather than uh
posting things of their own um and I I
block those things because I think it's
a false it's a phony chorus but there
are some real people involved in doing
this too and um they
they are't again the really interesting
thing is to be in my shoes because
they'll say things about like well yeah
about the timing of that Tucker
interview right now I know exactly what
the timing of that Tucker interview was
because I was in conversation text
conversation with Tucker and I told him
I said you know um in both cases both of
these interviews I alerted him to
something I alerted him to the World
Health Organization stuff and I said do
you know what this is and he said kind
of and I explained it to him and he said
do you want to come do an interview okay
that's how that interview happened right
and then the same thing happened I
talked to him a little bit before I went
to Panama with Zach and then uh on
getting back I texted him and I was like
this stuff is incredible and he's like
how about coming back to do it so the
point is what was the timing I mean the
timing was that I initiated a
conversation which told him there was
something interesting to talk about
right so I get I'm going to try to do
devil's advocate here
y we are all trying to make sense of
what we are seeing no many of us are
trying to make sense of what we are
seeing right so some people are just
being obnoxious or nasty or both um but
of that majority of us who are trying to
make sense of what we're seeing uh some
of the things that we look for are
strange timings and um and
collaborations we weren't expecting and
oh I didn't expect that guy to have that
opinion right
um thing anything that throws an error
uh we sort of put up on this you know
imaginary board in our in our head of
like okay you know do I or do I not
trust this guy or what do I think about
this issue or actually there's too like
I just don't know right and so I think
um you know as I've as I've begun to say
like look unless I've seen it directly
or you are one of a very small number of
people uh who has seen it directly
I don't know if it's true right so you
know the stuff coming the stuff coming
across the screens from all over the
world ACR you know from all variety of
of opinions all variety of domains by
and large at this point I I say I don't
know if that's true I this is an insane
way to live but I do not know if that is
true and uh you know and of course as we
have discussed endlessly um this is true
in scientific papers now too where you
know used used to be that I thought you
know direct experience with the skills
of observation um or the direct
experience with the skills of
observation of one of very few people
who I trust um is telling me what they
saw even though if I had been there I
might have seen something different uh
and the scientific literature
because the scientific literature is
written in a way that you can sus out
what they actually saw as opposed to
them only telling you what they think it
means
unless they're lying about the data or
they didn't collect the data um and and
the people they got the data from are
lying about it or the biggest way that
this is done now in the scientific
literature is yeah actually it's not
really about the data it's a model and
this is the one thing that I want to
talk about today which fits very well
with what you're talking about with
regard to models and collusion is well
once you're in model territory all
that'ss are rough like and and unless
you know the particular models or how or
or someone else is coming on like okay I
looked at their model and here's how
they arrived at you know this one
parameter that if you just talk if you
just move that one the entire model
falls out differently and oh well you
know the World Health policy was based
on that one little flipped switch Y and
how how can you tell how like I I say
that as someone who has read a stupid
amount of scientific literature and has
begun now and you know forever with
frankly the climate papers kind like I'm
sorry guys show me the paper with data
uh and I still need to know that you
took your data right and that those data
are what you say they are but if all
you're doing is putting this through
models and everything in your results is
is Model results I don't care no there's
no way to know no it is a completely
inappropriate use of models yeah um
models can generate hypothesis they
can't test them right
um but you're describing the cartisian
crisis right if you didn't see it or if
the information didn't come from
somebody that you know you deal with it
with extreme skepticism uh that is born
of having seen what appears to be
reliable conclusions uh turn out not to
be on closer inspection and that is that
is absolutely where we are um so I guess
before we close this out I want to just
show something and I don't mean to be
picking on David Ike although he's seems
to be picking on me he needs me to
disappear I guess but um anyway could
you put up David Ike's uh tweet about
Joe Rogan and Joe Rogan's apparent new
deal with
Spotify okay so David Ike I think I'm
pronouncing his name correctly says why
would someone who is a quote threat to
the system unquote be paid $250 Million
by the system to broadcast on mainstream
internet platforms owned by the system
the naive is shocking so many who think
they are awake are really uh still in a
coma Joe Rogan signs a new Spotify deal
with oh so then he's just quoting a
headline well well but for those who
aren't um watching Joe Rogan signs new
Spotify deal worth a $250 $250 million
that will spread his podcast across
multiple platforms including on Apple
Amazon and YouTube I know this is not
the point of what you're talking about
here but cool go Joe yeah yeah yeah
absolutely uh Jo's doing amazing work
now Spotify did did narrow uh his his
reach a little bit yeah will you put up
my uh okay so I said I quote tweeted
David Ike and I said regarding Joe Rogan
David Ike asks why would someone who's a
threat to the system be paid $250
Million by the system to broadcast on
mainstream internet platforms owned by
the system and I said because David the
system isn't a coherent whole it is an
emergent property made up of factions
that can be played against each other
Spotify is competing against Google and
X which puts it at Cross purposes with
the who Bill Melinda Gates Foundation
and DNC Etc in other words we just want
a significant Victory though some will
see it as a defeat so my point there is
not that there are is not collusion in
the system my point is that there is not
one faction you have M you have at least
multiple factions colluding who may want
different things right Goliath is a
strategy not an entity Goliath contains
collusion but it is not one single
Global conspiracy as far as we can tell
now David ik May disagree with that but
the point is he has put to he has put
forward a logical challenge which is it
you know if Joe Rogan is really a
problem for the system then the system
would not be paying him and the answer
is no that's not true because
Spotify is a corporation is it part of
something else I don't know but it's at
least a corporation and making a deal
with Joe Rogan that brings in a profit
May function against the interests of
the DNC it may function against the
interests of the who but the point is
that is not evidence of some grander
thing in which Joe Rogan is really a
part of it even though how many people I
mean do you really want to have gone to
battle over covid and not have Robert
Malone reaching 10 million an audience
of 10 million people right it's just a
it's a loser of a battle right that was
that was a major Victory and so anyway a
model that straight jackets you where
you cannot Escape it because it is
constructed in such a way that evidence
that goes in either Direction all
establishes the same thing which you're
saying which is it's all a plot right
that's not clever thinking it's very
very sloppy and uh I don't mean to take
the last word here David Ike responded
to me that what I
said revealed that I'm a dummy you want
to put that up he says Mr Weinstein if
I've ever read confirmation that you
have no idea how it all works then this
is it so thanks for that I have been
researching this full-time for 34 years
and I don't need to be told how things
operate by someone who bought covid Lock
Stock and the other thing and the other
thing and explained during the fake
pandemic how he wore a scarf around his
neck at home so he could pull it over
his face when he answered the door I I
called Co for what it was a hoax from
the start of 2020 because I had spent 30
years researching the cabal and its
methods for operation you bought it
because you hadn't that clearly still
applies now I would point out a couple
things
here this mask thing yep I was wrong
masks were not useful against covid not
significantly was I a fool to think they
might be no until we knew that there was
no fomite trans Mission then there was a
decent chance that masks would at least
have some value because they would keep
droplets that contain the virus from
hitting a surface from getting to that
surface in some percentage of the
instances and that would result in a
somewhat fewer instances of infection so
do I feel like a terrible person for uh
advocating for masks no was I wrong yes
um what are we to think about this as an
indication of the quality of my thinking
uh I don't know that I'm a fallible
person who worked from a data set that
was heavily polluted and became smarter
over time and I'm comfortable with that
final thing I will say about it is I am
perfectly happy with you evaluating my
record on covid warts and all but the
way you do that the rigorous way to do
that is to think of it as a question of
area under the curve so my advocacy of
masks and my advoc advocacy of masks I
don't know what I said about about
mandating masks I know that I advocated
for masks because it seemed a lowc cost
and likely to do some good and that I at
the point the evidence that it didn't do
any good I abandoned it I was always uh
appalled by the idea of using them
Outdoors Etc so if you take the harm
that was done by my advocacy of masks
and I will agree there was some harm if
you take that harm and you say there's
an area under the curve of that harm and
then you take the area under the curve
of uh if you compare it to the harm that
might have been done by people being
vaccinated who weren't vaccinated
because they watched our podcast and
realized that there was something wrong
with that story and their understanding
of what these things were composed of
and How likely they were to be perfectly
harmless right the point is the net
effect that we had on covid was
distinctly positive and if you want to
do that net analysis great if you want
to pick one thing and harp on it
endlessly then that's your sloppy
thinking and it's not our responsibility
well and I think um I mean I I hadn't
seen this interchange before um and I
don't I I I recognize the name but I
don't I don't really know who he is um
but going from what he claims about what
his work has been um I'm reminded of
this is going to sound like a total n
seator at first but I'm reminded of
myself as a young person uh going into
college I wanted to be a writer that's
what I wanted to do and I very quickly
realized in my literature and writing
courses and I was also taking science
because I specifically wanted to be a
science fiction writer but I wanted to
be a writer I quickly realized
especially in the creative writing
classes that um all the turns of phrase
and grammatical skill in the world
doesn't give you anything to write about
and so you know writing is a tool and
it's can be an art form um but it's not
sufficient you need to actually know
something and so I think I feel the same
way and again I don't I don't know what
it is that he claims to have exactly you
know how it is that he frames what he is
what he
does but people who um you know who
whose job they understand themselves to
be to you know figure out where everyone
else is getting it
wrong feels a little bit like that like
you know what that's not actually either
a particularly honorable but more to the
point um truth seeking position and uh
and here is where you and I landed on
one and you know this is our bias but we
think it is the right one that
evolutionary
biologists
train uh in the complexity of the world
where uh the things that seem totally
inobvious and turn out to be true
there's just no question it's a social
phenomenon you're going to have to
reconcile well like she said this and he
said that it's like no it's in front of
you the forest is what the forest is the
reef is what the reef is the bats the
Frog whatever it is and this
seems impossible I cannot reconcile this
what am I not seeing like it at the end
of the day when you have one of those
and its nature and you're an
evolutionary
biologist you have to keep digging what
don't I know what did I get wrong which
of my assumptions is flawed where like
where is the error in my understanding
of the universe because the fact is the
universe is doing this thing it doesn't
make sense according to the model I've
got therefore I know that I need to keep
looking I need to keep taking that is
the training that you had and that I
have had and that that is how we
approach everything even when it seems
to most people like what you know what's
evolutionary biology got to do with it
well everything almost always you know
unless it's unless it's rocks or quazars
it's evolutionary and it is that
training that you know you know you were
thinking about collusion and conspiracy
uh a lot uh for decades before before Co
but you were also thinking about
rainforests and the you know the
patterns of biodiversity on the planet
and the evolution of morality and the
evolution of inessence and cancer and
all of these other extraordinarily
complex systems which you know every
single one of those you had to apply a
similar toolkit in its you know in its
generality but the precise things were
very different and so when you start
applying that to an understanding of
political systems and you know
how how freaking NIH might be in
collusion with the
CCP okay um didn't do that one before
but here are all the tools that we bring
to bear on this let's go so you know
we're we you and I um later to be
thinking about Wuhan and the CCP than
those who were focused on the CCP for
years in advance sure
and like you're always going to be later
than someone there's one person who's
first and uh this it feels you know what
it feels like this feels like an
analogous argument to cultural
appropriation you know if if you if you
weren't the person who invented it then
you have no business here well come on
guys like enough already this is
ridiculous it is ridiculous and I I
would exactly along the lines that you
are arguing the diversity of the toolkit
right is actually the strength and it
may be if you want to just say hey I was
the first person to spot that they were
lying because I knew where they were
lying for years before they started
lying you know if you want to do that
then well okay how operationalizable is
that right how much good did you
actually do right all you've done is
preserve your ability to claim you and
you're caly like you can do that thing
forever right along that line but did
you did you have a mechanism whereby uh
mRNA shots cause myocarditis did you
spot that that is actually going to be
true for anything you load into that
platform has nothing to do with Spike
did you figure out a
volumetric uh uh model for how to avoid
Contracting covid when you can't uh
avoid interacting with people or any
respiratory pathogen any respiratory
pathogen um you know all of these things
come together and the utility comes from
the ab ility to see all of these pieces
you know do we deserve credit for
calling attention to vitamin D as a
mechanism for increasing your immunity
to all manner of things yes did we spot
it first nope did we claim to nope in
fact if you go back you'll see we
highlight the people that we learned it
from right so anyway um I think we made
the point stop being sloppy about this
there is something antagonistic to our
interests out out there it is telling us
lots of phony stuff about pandemics it
seems to be priming us for the next one
based on all manner of nonsense and the
what makes it happiest is when we fight
amongst ourselves for credit or we
shoehorn people into a straight jacket
to mix those two metaphors uh in order
to validate uh you know our own egos or
whatever that's that's not doing anybody
any good so it
out oras the shirt says cut that
out yeah we should send a shirt to him
not a bad
idea um okay uh I want to talk just a
little bit about uh healthy diets and
how we know and this obviously that that
topic could be you know many many
lifetimes of conversation and this
particular place that I want to go could
also be many lifetimes and and so we're
just going to skate on the surface um
because it it really it actually really
does fit with what you were talking
about with regard to models and
collusion and such so uh in
2019 the Lancet published a massive
report known as the eat lanet Commission
on food planet and health uh you can
just show my screen briefly here uh the
actual title of the paper is food and
the anthropos the eat Lancet Commission
on healthy diets from sustainable food
system
and it's a paper with tons and tons of
authors uh and um indeed uh eat some
sort of a cutesy it's an acronym and I
don't even I don't remember what yeah
yeah they're not trying to eat the
Lancet um but yes so the eat Lancet
Commission on healthy diets from
sustainable Food Systems um and it
provides uh it provided 2019 was
published I didn't know about it until
this week but um it provided dietory
advice that would it claimed provide for
both healthier um human lives but also
uh healthier planet
since publication that paper published
in the Lancet and commission it was a
Lancet e Lancet commission um has become
one of the top 20 most discussed science
papers across all of
Academia um cited as of the publication
of uh of a paper just this last uh in
this last month that I'll be mentioning
Stanton 2024 um cited four and a half
years out by uh over 4,500 other papers
which you know given the time it takes
to publish papers that's extra ordinary
um and maybe more remarkable by 631
policy documents okay so this is an
important document right like this and
given what it's what its claim is like
we got it we got the thing that you all
should be doing with regard to eating to
make yourself healthier and the planet
healthier here it is um
so um let's see let me pull up the
uh sorry uh
yeah here we go so here's uh just a PDF
of that same thing food and theanthropos
the eat lantic Commission on healthy
diets from sustainable Food Systems uh
the executive summary is what it is uh
it's you know a lot of public policy
stuff we quantitatively describe a
universal healthy reference diet to
provide a basis for estimating the
health and environmental effects of
adopting an alternative diet to Standard
current diets many of which are high and
unhealthy Foods scientific targets for a
healthy reference diet are based on
extensive literature on Foods dietary
patterns and health outcomes this
healthy reference diet largely consists
of vegetables fruits whole grains
legumes nuts and unsaturated oils
includes a low to moderate amount of
seafood and poultry and includes no or a
low quantity of red meat processed meat
added sugar refined grains and starchy
vegetables the global average intake of
healthy foods is substantially lower
than reference diet intake whereas overc
consumption of unhealthy Foods is
increasing using several approaches we
found with a high level of certainty
that Global adoption of the reference
dietary pattern P would provide major
health benefits including a large
reduction in total
mortality okay so there's one particular
um the a paper came out uh sometime in
the last week or two um by a professor
out of Ireland I think she
is uh saying basically what the hell um
I went digging I went looking and I see
um I see error after error in your
statistical analyses in your data in the
models that you've used and I don't know
how you could possibly make be making
the claims that you're making and she
goes after a number of of the of their
recommendations but the one I want to
focus on and one of the ones that she
focuses on is this bit about what you
should be doing is eating no red meat at
all okay no red meat so um let's see her
the her new paper uh is
this uh perspective unacceptable if you
would share my screen unacceptable use
of substandard metrics and policy
decisions which mandate large reductions
in animal Source Foods uh and the whole
uh actually here I'm going to read the
um the abstract um many recent very
influential reports including those from
the global burden of disease risk factor
collaborators the eat lanet Commission
on food Planet Health and the lanet
countdown on health and climate change
have recommended dramatic reductions or
total exclusion of animal Source Foods
particularly ruminant products red meat
and dairy from the human diet they
strongly suggest that these dietary
shifts will not only benefit planetary
Health but also human health however as
detailed in this perspective the paper
that she's writing there are grounds for
considerable concern in regard of the
quality and transparency of the input
data the validity of the assumptions and
the appropriateness of the statistical
modeling used in the calculation of the
global Health estimates which underpin
the claimed human health benefits the
Lesser bioavailability of protein and CH
micronutrient nutrients from plant
Source Foods versus animal Source Foods
was not adequately recognized nor
addressed in any of these reports
furthermore assessments of bias and
certainty were either limited or absent
despite many of these errors and
limitations being publicly acknowledged
by the gbd and the eat Lancet authors no
Corrections have been applied to the
published papers as a consequence these
reports continue to erroneously
influence food policy decisions and
international dietary guidelines such as
the World Wildlife funds Live Well diet
and the Nordic nutrition recommendations
2023 so
again I'm sort of you know skating along
the surface here going this paper this
this commission published in 2019 says
basically stop eating red meat and dairy
and that paper which has been uh cited
over 4,500 times in scientific papers
and over 630 times in policy papers is
now the basis the basis for dietary
guidelines being put out by other
organizations that have their own imp
premature of seriousness right and so
it's like seriousness on top of
seriousness but these are like really
unserious Turtles actually all the way
down like they're not actually what they
appear like these are like skin suit
organizations and you go back to a paper
um the same lead author the Stanton 2024
that I was just reading from in
2022 she uh with a few other authors
published uh a letter in the Lancet in
correspondence called 36-fold higher
estimate of deaths attributable to red
meat intake in gbd 2019 is this reliable
so she goes back there was a report from
the same group eat lanet uh in 2017 just
two years earlier and she says she and
her authors here say her co-authors here
say to what might you attribute a
36-fold higher estimate of mortality due
to eating red meat just two years later
what happened what what do we now know
about the dire effects of eating red
meat that we did not know before so
actually if I can just have my screen
back for a moment to remind myself where
we are here um yeah okay so you can you
can show my
screen what they
did was um there is something known in
this I didn't even know what to call
this field like Global Public Health
diet dietary nut nutrition something
they're using um many many measures one
of them is the theoretical minimum risk
exposure tmal which um and in my my sort
of vernacular understanding of what this
is It's the exposure level that is how
much food or nutrients you're actually
ingesting uh that minimizes the risk of
death from all causes related to a
single risk factor so it's some kind of
like aggregate data thing where in
creating a model as the authors of the
eat lanet study did they assigned for
everything for you know fruits for green
leafy vegetables for red meat for
process Meats for dairy a
TM
level and where they got that is pretty
obscure and indeed in this case where
they got it was based on data that they
had collected which they oops hadn't
really published like no actually they
hadn't published it at all so they these
authors say you got to show us these
data and they finally have released
those data and they're also unreliable
and ridiculous but based on these these
data that uh that were in this 2019
report uh that are either non-existent
or don't say what they said they should
say they set the tmal again that's the
theoretical minimum risk exposure level
for red
meat to
zero I think it should be even lower
they just set it to zero so this is
claiming to be research and it's a model
it which they set the only safe level of
ingesting red meat to zero and then wow
they acted surprised when what they got
out of the model was it turns out that
eating red meat any red meat at all is
gonna cause harm yeah and so these
authors who are saying whoa whoa whoa
whoa wait a minute um have a number
of a number of wonderful things that
they say in resp response uh let me just
read one more one more thing this is
again from the Stanton it all 2022
letter to the lanc in response to this
ridiculous but very important in terms
of setting expectations for what we
should be eating worldwide 2019 study
out of the Lan the Assumption of a red
meat tmal of zero is counterintuitive
given the role of meat in evolutionary
diets and contemporary Hunter gathered
populations I was going to point that
out myself in which cardio and with
regard to the Contemporary hun gathered
populations in which cardio metabolic
diseases were and still are
uncommon furthermore recently published
results from one of the largest
multinational studies which was
conducted in five continents and
examined the association between
different types of meat and health
outcomes the perspective Urban rural
epidemiology study contradicts this
premise it is of considerable importance
that the gbd 2019 risk factors
collaborators provide the empirical
evidence for this change in tmal and
confirm that there was no projection
beyond the available evidence we further
question that the totality of
nutritional effects of red meat have
been considered in The Meta regressions
if the tmal is assumed to be zero red
meat would then de facto be presented as
an inherently harmful food the assum
this assumption would ignore the
well-documented nutritional benefits
with respect to the supply of essential
nutrients and bioactive
components in a
nutshell we've got a report from
2019 that was based on
evidence that was um not public never
published um after having been asked to
release it they have just released it
and it is riddled with errors and
statistical Shenanigans and um and and
just general chicanery scientific
chicanery and yet it is that report
which is forming the basis for Global
guidelines for the reduction of red meat
intake for every human being on the
planet the look read me decide there is
too much chicanery in our diet I think
that is yeah clear absolutely and
there's a way so first of
all a thousand versions of money
printers here absolutely you have a
scientific monkeying with the Baseline
monkey with the Baseline and if we can
only get our particular thing into the
scientific literature dressed up as if
it was the result of research that tells
us what we should now be eating which by
the way isn't going to affect our dinner
party at all but we're you know yeah
we're going to ignore it um maybe we'll
even laugh about it but you guys should
stop eating red meat because this very
scientific this very sciency paper so
sciency um says that you should and I
think the point is look the food pyramid
was garbage remember the food pyramid oh
so comforting geometrically speaking um
I mean it was really very very good
stuff because it was so intuitive and
easy to follow and well wrong that was
the problem with it but remember how we
were supposed to laugh at people who
thought there was Pyramid Power and like
we going and sitting inside pyramids and
and yet we were supposed to not in any
way laugh at these people at the food
pyramid people yeah who appear to be
equally crazy yeah
but we have like an infinite
series of abuses of people's tendency
not to investigate the content of
deductive logic I realize that's a
really convoluted way to say this but if
yeah this bunch of things that you're
not going to read and if you did you
probably wouldn't understand them is
true then this conclusion is
unavoidable right it's like okay I mean
in people are case they literally just
took the slider was like just set it to
zero set it to zero set it to zero let's
just like start with the assumption that
red meat is really bad for you and it's
always going to increase death and then
let's pretend that we didn't set that as
an assumption and claim it's the
conclusion yeah like classic modeling
chiner again let Set red meat to death
and see what happens in our model we'll
just see whether how much red meat we
should be even eating given that red
meat is death right um so yeah
but it counts on the fact that even the
pros who are citing this how many
freaking times over 4,500 times in 4 and
a half years and that doesn't even
account for the fact that it takes a
long time to get stuff published right
so the pros are falling all over
themselves to embrace and site a model
that's obviously nonsense that you know
and it how much does this look like the
icton stuff where the fact is well the
evidence is clear that ivera doesn't
work evidence based on what method oh a
very complex method in which we shifted
all of these things well what if you
know let's say we give Alexander marinos
a couple of weeks to scrutinize that
method what's going to find in there you
know oh my goodness he finds all kinds
of malons and you know what would be
necessary to figure out how important
they were we need to see the data when
are we going to see the data never it's
not going to be released right so it's
like that game that is on a need to know
basis and we need for you not to know we
really need for you not to know and
especially not to tell Alex but um yeah
it's yeah it's a it's a it's some kind
of shell game and the thing is the food
pyramid was not broken by accident it
was broken by lobbyists right who needed
the food pyramid to recollect a
particular diet based on sugar lobbyists
Chrisco lob Cal grains and stuff right
and the point is how how many people
died early because they believed the
food pyramid that was presented to them
that was actually the result of lobbying
and not science you know lots of them so
the amount of harm done to people was
you know immeasurable and we you know
can look back on it now and say huh
that's a bunch of crap right aren't we
clever but okay that what's the latest
science say well the latest science
isn't any any more scientific right
likewise you know the the American Heart
Association right how long did I listen
to the American Heart Association on the
basis that they were at least you know
maybe they were a little heart
association they were overly focused on
the heart but I you know at least we can
figure out what's good for you by
listening to them well you know the seed
oil involvement in the creation of this
thing is you know conspicuous decades
after you know the the harm is done yeah
we can discover that actually you know
it's in some sense the product of a
trade group right um so yeah raises
questions I didn't I did not um go and
look into any of the authors of the
study I don't know you know I I don't
know what their perverse incentives are
but I'm I bet we could find them and
even if you can't the question is yeah
it at the end of the day it doesn't it
doesn't matter if they just took the
slider and sent it to zero and then went
aha our assumption is become our
inclusion therefore don't eat red meat
that's not the way you're all you're
like you logically and scientifically
and morally and ethically and all the
rest of it but logically you cannot do
that and the evolutionary point that the
critic makes right yes was definitely on
my mind of points to raise right what
are the chances that a species in which
most of its populations had red meat as
a major component of their diet is
actually harmed by the very fact of
eating red meat and the extent remnants
of those populations have far fewer
cardi metabolic diseases than the people
eating the weird diet right huh yeah and
what are that you know red meat is not a
novel product of some process so the
fact that we like it that's probably the
result of a long evolutionary history
that's proof that we're
immoral but you know and you know you
don't remember the old joke uh God
didn't want us eating uh animals why did
he make them out of meat right um you
know
it's it is it is kind of this point
right it's one thing when you're dealing
with something novel that you don't have
the ability to evaluate its quality
because your ancestors didn't have it
but our ancestors had a lot of access to
red meat yep we like it for a reason
there are differences in how that meat
is raised the more it is raised in a
manner that is similar to the animals
that our ancestors ate the better off
you are shocking that yep um but you can
also make the animal Sick by giving them
a diet high in grains funny that yeah
it's the animal's fault for believing
the food
pyramid yes feed lot cattle shouldn't
have been reading up on what the USDA
thinks they should be eating you know I
don't know if this is in their defense
but they are very gullible animals so
cows yes so the fact that they were uh
buying into the food pyramid is perhaps
at least predictable but um but the
other thing is look we know that meat is
not inherently bad as a food substance
right let us all agree we know it
because lions and leopards don't have a
problem with it but so but but we're not
lions and Le no no no no let me finish
the point lions and leopards don't have
a problem therefore biologically
speaking it is not an unsolvable problem
that red meat causes for those who
consume it it's been solved in Lions so
now given that our ancestors we can't
eat cellulose and termites can are in a
symbiotic relationship with organisms
that can and they can digest this is a I
mean I get it but this is a false
analogy my point is Lions don't have ill
effects from red meat so it's not like
red meat is a toxin okay our ancestors
ate red meat for millions of years so
the point is what are the chances that a
solvable problem given millions of years
of opportunity for evolution to solve
the problem remained unsolved at the
level that the actual level that we can
tolerate is zero I would say the chances
of that being right are near zero right
right yes they they approach zero right
so they absolutely do whereas uh the
idea that it's kind of pretty much okay
to have some stuff in your diet that was
invented
yesterday on an evolutionary time scale
you know if it was invented in the 20th
century and that isn't having its slider
sent all the way to zero uh you know and
some of the stuff that was invented in
the 20th century it's probably going to
be okay for us but in general minimize
that stuff and maximize the stuff that
you're you know that a in Michael
pollen's words that your grandmother
would recognize as food and that you can
be certain uh your ancestors have been
eating for at least thousands if not
tens hundreds of thousands millions of
years well the way to do the question
about the stuff that's recently been
invented is you don't necessarily know
if it's harmful but what you do know is
that it's not safe that's right right
because the point is an mRNA vaccine
right to say something is safe is to say
it is without risk and when something is
truly novel it is not without risk you
don't know what its long-term
implications are you don't know what its
implications are for epigenetic
regulation of stuff well this I mean
this this is exactly the position that
we have had on GMOs since the 90s right
since I mean I remember I remember
teeing a class at University of Michigan
in like one of our first years in grad
school you know mid
mid90s and it was it was one of these
like biology for non- Majors classes and
we had a paper on GMOs and even then it
was just abundantly clear like okay yes
that sounds like Franken food but put
that aside like get over your like
aversion to it because it sounds not
right think instead about what that
aversion means like why are you
squeamish about something that has never
before been together uh evolutionarily
that means it's not tested that means
that we just don't no and the slide of
hand there is something that we can
unpack right you can focus on the
actual food stuff the creature that's
been genetically modified and you can
say we can demonstrate no harm right
okay did you test it in light of the
farming practice that it Alters did you
test it with respect to tradeoffs in
other words you have made one strain
tolerant to some pesticide which
probably isn't good for you um but in
order to get
the uh the insert that allows it to be
tolerant you have chosen a strain and
the point is did was that strain optimal
with respect to all of the other
parameters or did you sacrifice those
parameters in order to get to be
tolerant to some herbicide right so the
point is there's lots of logical reasons
to wonder about how healthy that thing
is and whether or not it contains risks
we don't know but the presentation is
very much like that paper the
presentation is pseudoscientific and it
sounds like this it sounds like this it
goes um human beings have been
genetically modifying organisms for
thousands of years this is not different
this is just simply a matter of us doing
what our ancestors have done yes in a
newer higher Tech way but there's
nothing new how could genetically
modifying an organism be inherently bad
if that is literally all of our food
crops and all of our animal
right and the point is okay that is
exactly what it sounds like that's what
it sounds like and the problem is it it
comes in the calm measured tones of the
wouldbe scientist wearing the lab coat
and holding the glasswear and they're
wrong right they're wrong and the point
is most people who do not have
the training to spot what's wrong in
that seemingly logical presentation
right they are belittled into not
raising their questions by the idea that
they are being supers ious and they are
actually frightened of something that is
not only not harmful but logically
incapable of being bad as many people
were uh hounded into accepting the co
Dogma sure around the vaccines around um
off label use of drugs like itin and
hydroxy chloroquin to treat because
anyone who began to raise questions
about this if you didn't have
and courage may not be exactly the right
word but the courage of your
convictions based usually on you know
either cynicism just like I'm going to
go against what these people say because
I know they tend to be wrong and that's
the safest bet or a history of trying to
navigate like no I know that they've
lied to me because they can't possibly
be safe therefore what else what else
might they be lying to me about and what
can we know for sure that that it was it
was the same
shaming technique that we that we saw um
on a on a slower scale with regard to
GMOs in the 90s as those were being
tried out actually very much the same
thing it is the same in in this
way there were two things that were
possibly wrong with you if you didn't
buy their vaccine Dogma one of them was
that you
were mentally feeble MH right that you
didn't understand how well these things
had been tested and how much you were
freaking out over nothing um and the
other is that you were morally deficient
and that you were a parasite who was
going to um put Grandma at risk in order
to hedge out the tiniest of risks that
you would expose yourself here's a third
one cowardly scared of needles scared of
yeah that one didn't stick so well but I
I agree that was deplo but I that's one
that I saw testimonials um of the
converted I got over my fear of needles
and I went and got the jab yep but the
idea of mentally feeble and morally
deficient I can't prove I'm neither it
is also what's going on with all of this
um pseudo wisdom that is emerging on the
food stuff right it's like oh here's a
bunch of handw science um that
uh you're going against if you eat that
stuff and what's more you're killing the
planet you know you're just bad right
that's what's wrong with you and you
know these things are really your desire
for a hamburger is worth destroying the
planet right exactly and so the the
problem is that we uh humans are
emotional beings that can be made
defensive by these kinds of arguments
right you want to prove that you're not
stupid and so you want to live by their
guidelines so you can demonstrate that
you understood their paper which is not
comprehensible because it's wrong right
um or you want to demonstrate that
you're more than doing your part
uh for a good old planet Earth and you
know look I love this planet like no
other I'm really fond of it MH but you
me both man yeah I mean it it's been
good to us I have to say of all the
planets that we've been to this one's
been the best and not by a small margin
so um all right but in any case the the
manipulation via these emotional
channels that then results in pseudo
analytical analytical conclusions is a
pattern that we should just get good at
spotting because this isn't the last
time they're going to use it on this oh
no it's not
no all right um there are a couple of
things that you were thinking about
maybe talking about uh we've been going
for a while couple hours already um did
you want to did you want to go to either
uh yeah let's let's talk about the
orcas briefly um so story emerged this
week and I have to tell you that this is
a tough story for me because um I
connect it with my reaction to uh
roadkill animals that have been killed
on the road which I have always had
trouble with right I I am not an
uncaring person when it comes to harms
to people but there's something about
animals killed by cars that just it it
hits me hard every time and so anyway
maybe that's a defect in my character
that I feel it as viscerally as I do but
anyway story emerged
yesterday um this is not about roadkill
it is about a pod of orcas and this PO
of
orcas was trapped in some sea ice off of
Northern Japan Al kaido yeah um and it
was a a large pod um including several
calfs and this really got my attention
because there's
a there are pods of work as up here
where we live and recruiting you know a
year in which a calf you know is born
and makes it to next year is a big deal
around here this is a a a tough process
so anyway the idea I me the inner birth
interval at a minimum I think is two
years and sometimes it's way longer than
that so and a lot of the Cals don't
survive and so anyway um you want to
show the video of these trapped
orcas oh my god um so here you have a L
of orcas in a small section that is ice
free bobbing up and down
clearly trying to breathe and you
imagine with the calves there they would
have an even harder time getting to the
surface than the adults and anyway the
the story struck me as um potentially
very tragic because number of things
were true one there didn't seem to be
any plausible plan for saving them and
while I can imagine that if there were
an ice breaker shipped nearby maybe it
would be doable there's a question about
the depth of the water anyway nobody
seemed to have a an idea of how to break
the ice to free these animals and it
looked like you know these are
warm-blooded creatures who were going to
exhaust themselves and die quickly um
and the idea you know we get very
focused if
a group of miners gets trapped in a mine
and we know that they're going to
suffocate and there's a race to save
them and and I understand why those
stories obsess us but these animals um
it was like that story you know these
are obviously incredibly intelligent
creatures and also not common I don't
think these particular orcas are
endangered but um the particular
population where they're coming from
yeah but nonetheless the this is like an
entire little lineage right right that
could be wiped out by having uh Gotten
Trapped By
the ice in this way apparently it's not
the first time this has happened but
anyway that struck me as a you know just
an awful predicament um now good news I
think is that as of today there's no
sign of them which people take could be
that they succumbed but I think although
it seems unlikely that they would all
have succumbed at once so I would I
would it it would it would seem that if
they were beginning to fail that there
would be fewer rather than none right
that none looks like Escape like Escape
yeah although it could be that as you
know you know these are intelligent
creatures they you know have a social
hierarchy it could be that it became
obvious that the only way out of this
was to attempt to swim under the ice
farther than and none of them none of
them made it that's a possibility too um
so I don't know I'm I'm I'm interested
to know what their fate was and and
concerned that no we may never know I
they weren't these weren't tagged
animals I don't think they weren't
tagged but they may be known because of
you know photo IDs and all not that They
Carried photo IDs they don't have
pockets but no they never get stopped
for speeding even though they're fully
capable of it oh sure um but people take
uh they have atlases of the
idiosyncrasies of their Dorsal fins and
their color pattern and so it's possible
that these are well-known animals um I
don't know
but anyway I thought this was an
interesting story for a number of
reasons one there's the
simple tragedy of it um the fact that
populations of orcas have been trapped
in this space a couple of times begins
to suggest an evolutionary question here
so yeah and so when you first told me
about this I was like Japan sea ice that
seems really far south and apparently
Hokkaido which is the northernmost
Island um where this was uh happening is
the southernmost point where there is
regular sea ice in the winter so it's
not unusual for there to be sea ice
there although you know I don't know
exactly what's going on with the
circulation in the Pacific that it's
that that does seem pretty far south for
thec it does um but to the extent that
this is a regular Hazard you would
imagine that there's an evolutionary
response in the whales um that they
would know that this was a hazard but
think about the following
question let's say that none of these
animals
survived well then you would have the
production over the course of I don't
know a decade of animals that would
replace them in the ecosystem right
there would be room in the ecosystem for
that many more
whales if if if other parameters are
um are stable then you expect other
populations to produce more surviving
Cals um that then end up creating a new
pod right so all else being equal we
expect those animals to be replaced
let's say that this has happened a
thousand
times that would create a very weak
selective Force for trepidation amongst
these whales about swimming into
whatever conditions result in them
getting trapped right because the new
whales are naive and so if there was a
little predisposition to be worried
about ice you know it might you know the
whales that didn't swim into the ice
would be more likely to produce that
population so there'd be a little bit of
evolutionary pressure but not much
whereas and this is actually a great
example of why some of us Critters
especially humans but also almost
especially uh toothed whales um and you
know uh Apes wolves and elephants and
apes and parrots and corvids crows the
long lived social generational overlap
long
childhoods in which our genomes have
offloaded so much of the work of
evolutionary adaptation to a cultural
layer right if these animals survived or
if any of them survived then what they
carry with them is the understanding
that that condition which seemed
reasonable enough to swim into was
actually
deadly right if all of them survived
they will have that knowledge because
they will have gone through this
terrifying experience and that
terrifying experience what is Terror
well terror is the you know all right
activate these contingency programs and
definitely remember this because it's
really important and you don't want to
end up in the situation again you know
so the sort of negotiation with God that
a human might go through like if I get
out of this I'll never do it again right
that kind of thing um you would imagine
that these whales would carry this as
the equivalent of a whale story however
it is encoded right even if what it is
is that the baby whales detect their
parents become you know concerned as
they swim near the ice and they don't
know exactly what it's about but they
know that ice is more dangerous than it
looks yeah well so I mean two of those
parameters I just gave in that list that
you're well familiar with long lived and
generational overlap right cultural
transmission of lessons learned from
earlier in life when you are yourself
old that is that is what all of those
organisms that I mentioned uh have the
capacity to do and this fits very neatly
with what is called the grandmother
hypothesis right so you know why and I'm
trying to remember is it Elephants or
orcas or is there some evidence in both
that they are the only other organisms
besides humans that go through menopause
go through menopause and so what is what
is the point of post- reproductive life
well if you're long lived and are social
and have generational overlap and you
have long childhoods and you have to
learn how to be who you are as opposed
to you're born and you're a giraffe and
within moments you can run from
leopards if you have to learn how to be
who you are there's going to be a lot of
value in continuing to impart those
Lessons Learned and generating new
lessons and um and figuring and engaging
in the act of discovery and creativity
long past when you might be producing
kids right and so the prediction of that
hypothesis is
that orcas or any creature that has a
grandmother will out compete all else
being equal will out compete a similar
individual who doesn't because the
benefit of the information that their
grandmother carries uh will provide a
material advantage because no no matter
how good your parents are or especially
if they're not very good uh your
grandmother and your grandfather um but
you know your your grandmother you know
is your grandmother if she's your
mother's mother um has been around for
longer has seen more she's lived she's
she has survived more things than your
parents have and while what she has
lived through in the lessons that she
has taken to Heart most may be farther
from your current circumstances because
more time has elapsed uh the fact is
that she did it she made it through and
she may remember that time that we were
trapped in the ice off Hokkaido and
here's what we did guys right especially
for things that have very low uh
periodicity right right the chances that
your grandmother saw it but your mom
didn't right is high and so uh the
advantage of having a grandmother who
knows uh is potentially the difference
between life and death so anyway I don't
know what's happened to these whales I
sure hope they made it out I sure hope
they made it out I mean it's such a a
remarkable and special creature and um
you know very sad if they exhausted and
drowned but let's hope they didn't and
you know and I hope and I hope less but
I hope that we find out yeah I do too I
I will be I will uh it will be forever
an open question until we do find out
yeah so I hope so too yeah um but anyway
I thought I thought what a fascinating
and terrifying circumstance yeah
indeed well I think we've arrived
I think we have done that I think we
have arrived uh so we will be back uh
next week same time same place uh please
consider coming over to rumble and
joining the Darkhorse channel it's
utterly free and you help us out with
with our numbers and also while you're
at it come join us on locals there's
been a watch party going on during our
live stream as there always is we put
guest episodes out there early and
there's a ton of great new content there
in the last couple of weeks uh emerging
from Brett and Zach's
uh recent trip to Panama into the Darian
and in the Panama Canal yes Zach and I
will say um this is Zach speaking that
Brett and I are going to do an AMA about
Panama so if you have questions um this
Friday on locals we I'm not sure exactly
the time yet but we are going to be
taking questions about that trip
specifically and answering them oh
fantastic we will be taking questions
but no prisoners on our are you not
saying to take any PR and is a an an
important direction we do not know if we
will be taking prisoners but we do not
intend to so anyway at support on locals
and you get to ask questions about that
trip if you uh you have any that's
fantastic yeah so uh come join us at at
locals um and yeah we got we got other
places that you can find us I write at
Natural Selections my substack uh we've
got the Darkhorse store.org where you
too can get your very own cut that
out shirt and I will point out that our
limited experimentation with this this
shirt in the family has established that
it comes in handy a
lot yes um also for those of you who um
are unhappy enough to live among uh mask
wearing authoritarians we have uh Jake's
micro pizza right delicious which uh it
comes in a variety of sizes all
microscopic all microscopic um we have a
number of toppings to choose from many
of them made from red meat oh yep but
all organic GMO free uh usually locally
soured although it depends on where in
fact you're buying your Jake's micro
Pizza we do not actually Supply the
pizza we do Supply the merch from Jake's
micro Pizza Store uh you can get it
comes with pizza now oh oh it comes with
pizza good we don't we're not having to
pay extra for that like no not even for
postage it is that small oh yeah I mean
it's kind of like homeopathic pizza so
it's at levels like levels homeopathic
Pizza that yeah it is it is homeopathic
pizza so levels are so small that you
just don't have to get the permitting
it's it's really in every way that a
pizza can be perfect it is perfect uh
unless you're hoping to fill up on pizza
then you should find a different Source
yeah if you're hungry Jake's micro Pizza
is not for you but if you would like to
be constantly eating so as to not have
to put on your mask this is your pizza
this is the pizza for you yes this is
this is your pizza um lots of other
great designs um at our store at
Darkhorse store.org
um I could use some micro
yes yeah um couldn't we all check out
our sponsors this week which were uh MD
hearing and armra and what was the first
one that I read I can't remember at the
moment oh Helix of course I was I it
just it it was so horrific um as it
should be because it's a mattress
company right yes no um so it's Helix
and armr and MD hearing all um our
sponsors this week check them out and
remember that we are supported by you we
are grateful to you join us at Rumble
join us locals um any number of other
places but also share and talk about
what you're hearing here and uh and uh
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well
everyone